we have gotta talk about the insanity
that Michael B Jordan went through to
prepare for his role as Adonis he was
working out like six days a week getting
ko'd in the boxing ring and running on
little to no sleep you're gonna need a
nap just after hearing about it Michael
actually learned how to box for this
role and even passed on a stunt double
for one of his major scenes resulting in
a gnarly punch to the face and not only
did it happen once it happened two wise
hopefully our guy's okay but considering
how intense his workout routine was more
on that in a little bit I'm assuming it
wasn't as bad as it looks Michael wanted
to learn how to box properly because he
didn't want the movie to fall short in
that aspect he wanted the film to be
different from other boxing movies and
part of that was him becoming a stellar
boxer the most difficult aspect was
getting the footwork right and
apparently that's key to being and of
course looking like a professional boxer
in order to get everything just right
the entire cast took part in what they
called a Creed Camp boxing training run
by Mark Rhino Smith and as you can
probably imagine the camp was intense I
knew we were gonna break a sweat I knew
we're gonna turn the heat up and we did
just that they did strength endurance
and cardio conditioning before they even
got into the boxing aspect they didn't
want anyone stepping into the ring
without being properly prepped to move
like a professional boxer and that fancy
footwork went on for six days a week
that's also how many days Michael did
other workouts to prepare for the role
needless to say the dude was huge after
only a few weeks a big part of this
training regime was because of his
personal trainer Corey Kaye he's been
working with Michael since 2014 and
couldn't turn down the challenge of
getting him in the best shape of his
life for the latest Creed film they
would work out multiple times a day
focusing on different groups of muscles
each time and throwing some outside of
creed Camp boxing in there and they had
to keep switching up the exercises due
to how much she was constantly working
out so apparently a lot of the workouts
that Michael would do each day came as a
surprise to him Corey wanted to keep him
and his body guessing if you keep doing
the same workouts every day your body
will get used to it and you won't feel
changes so the workaround is to keep
implementing new things so your body can
keep growing and adjusting some of these
specific workouts for those of you Gym
Rats were bicycle crunches lying leg
raises AB rollouts weighted rope
crunches and Russian twists for the
first 30 minutes they would start with
some cardio a warm-up and then full body
training like hit or calisthenics so in
between all these workouts which I'm
already exhausted just talking about
Michael B Jordan was running on little
to no sleep and if you thought I was
gonna say the opposite I'm just as
surprised as you are apparently though
according to Corey Michael was never
much of a sleeper as long as he's known
him so what would happen is Michael
would get to the point where he would
need a quick nap or eventually need to
take an entire day just to sleep the key
ingredient for any healthy body food
it's obviously important to eat
especially when you're working out as
much as Michael I think the diet was the
hardest thing for me to kind of wrap my
head around like let's talk about what
he ate tons and tons of turkey and rice
and I wasn't really expecting such a
Thanksgiving Vibe but literally the guy
ate turkey for breakfast lunch and
dinner who even likes turkey like that
he was allowed a little diversity though
once a week he was pretty much allowed
whatever he wanted and that actually
helped too Corey said that after Michael
would eat a burger his mussels would pop
more and his body wouldn't look so flat
so yeah the guy was hammering down
turkey protein shakes fruits vegetables
and the occasional Burger a key aspect
to getting him in shape for this movie
was being able to not only perform as
well as Adonis but to also perform well
as a director and for those of you who
don't know Michael also directed the
film Cory had to be super meticulous in
what he planned for him because he
didn't want to burn him out so much that
he had no Creative Energy left in him to
direct something Corey stated about this
was that you don't need to spend two and
a half hours in the gym to get in shape
you can accomplish a lot with shorter
workouts which brings us to our next
topic so I already talked about what
kind of workouts they were doing but the
key to making those exercises so
efficient was the way they were
compartmentalized Michael might train
three or four times a day it would be a
brief but super intense conditioning
workout in the morning midday they would
throw in boxing practice or bag work
then either cardio or another lifting
session in the evening and the goal was
to drive muscle growth and endurance
through short but intense training
sessions so yeah on the bright side you
don't need to hit the gym two hours a
day but you do have to give it
everything you got even if it's only for
30 minutes and there were definitely no
shortcuts with his workouts but one
thing Michael really enjoyed and took
advantage of was his ability to switch
things up on the Fly due to him being
his own director it was tough at times
because he was usually wearing boxing
gloves or a mouthpiece but he did save a
lot of time in other ways while the
cameras were rolling if I needed to move
you upstage a little bit I just move a
little bit like this and then I get the
shot that I need he described it as
low-key cheating but considering how
much the the guy was working his body to
capacity I'm all for him saving as much
time as possible anywhere else not the
boxing not the training and not even the
director were the hardest part of making
this film the boxing part of it is
probably the easiest the hardest part
was managing all of that in a timely
manner being able to like prep train and
prepare for the next day of shooting I
see why the guy wasn't sleeping the hard
part is when you're acting in the scene
and you feel like you're you're not
giving your scene partner you're all it
was
to be fully present when he was trying
to act direct and most likely stepping
onto set right after an intense workout
so it definitely makes every aspect of
this movie that much more impressive
Corey shared some advice for the average
folk too when he was asked how to stay
in shape over the holidays a big piece
of his advice was not to diet so yeah
diet culture not the vibe he says you
don't walk into a candy store and say
you're not there for the candy that
makes no sense he says the key to
staying in shape instead of trying to
eat less or cut back is just to train a
bit more you don't have to diet or
restrict yourself in order to achieve
your body goals some workouts he
recommends that don't involve any
equipment are burpees push-ups bicycle
crunches and standing high knees I
couldn't end the video without talking
about Jonathan majors and his intense
workout routine like he solely worked
with Mark Rhino Smith it's very intense
very productive very fun it's very fun
that is true the fun part is definitely
debatable in my opinion but like it's
clear Jonathan loves to
sometimes I might say 10 more than Jay
because of his mindset we'll do another
20. the workout he's doing there are
straight arm lat pulldowns which work
your lats mid-back and abs after they
smash those they head into the pull-ups
and hey
exhale and poop oh good so like who else
is thinking about using their unused gym
membership right now this is very
intense watch the ABS here how much is
working these are just a preview of the
workouts he does on a regular basis
Jonathan works with Mark on two body
parts every other day and they put them
together into what they call a superset
like he and Michael B Jordan are not
messing around here if they're playing
professional boxers they don't want any
aspect of that to look like a
performance like do you think he could
handle all these workouts and intense
boot camps just to get into character
we're done Michael B Jordan was put
through the ringer literally in this
film along with the rest of his hard
work and co-stars and honestly I'm even
more impressed after finding out that
he's acting directing and boxing on like
little to no sleep and basically living
off of turkey protein shakes so like
which part of his prep do you think you
would have had the most trouble with let
me know down in the comments
foreign